[音楽]
おっ
本文
000地下感動が出せませんでした
お久しぶりで佐渡社長で言い訳をさせてください
言い訳てがもシンプルなことなんですけども東京に3日かいましてその3日間がもう
ほとんど
朝から夜までいろんなお仕事とか撮影とかイベントとかそんな事やっててあの全く動画
を撮るタイミング
場所いう
そんな要素でも動画が撮れなくて二日間休んでしまいました
大変申し訳ございませんですよとは言わないんですけどなぜなら私は毎日投稿しますか
一言も言ったことはない
謝ることじゃないんですけどモコ前的にはなるべく
動画だしたいなと思ってて正直2日連続安んだろうがちょっとあの僕の中ですごい
苦しいですと言う
やしなんか東京でビッカが入ったんですけどもちょーでー
[音楽]
ケリをつけようと思いますもう前からずっと言ってるわけですよ
静岡に住んでるかな東京行くと道が取れなくなる
うーん東京に引っ越そうかなんでも静岡いいなぁってこう色々言ってたんですけど結局
のかまだ静岡に止まってるから今回みたいなことが起きてしまった心のどこかで本末
転倒している木がさってやっぱりメインの動画を出して初めて棒
9 u 2バーの仕事やってますって言うんでそこが大楚歌になるとやっぱぼく何か
なぁ
これ違うんだろうなって思ってたりかといって投票行かないわけにもいきませんし
そして僕にはもう仲間がいます畑というための仲間もいるから結局で書店がどこになる
かっていうのがすごい今ますます大事になってます何ならもう畑でも東京行くことが
ありますからね
実はん
今週も3回3日間と言ってるんですけどさに水末でもう1回畑で東京いくんで週4回
東京
週間の半分以上東京にいるわけでございます正直に言わせていただきます
このままだと動画が撮れません結構
あのそろそろマジでやばいなと思ったけどやっぱり僕は静岡が大好きですできる限り
静岡にいたいという想いも相当強いし
なんか東京に行くと東京に染まりそうで僕は心配ですはじめ出張ですどうすればいい
ですか
静岡にいたいっても東京にいた方が動画
出せるもう何だななんか愛知とか言っちゃってもいいんじゃないみたいで北海道沖縄
リーダーいろんな
ないはそれは東京に行くべきかすると彼に残るべきかすごい
僕正直あのイーブンなんですよね静岡でも無理すれば道が出せるし
東京だったらなんか時間もできるし畑ついにどうすればすぐ時間も確保できる
さあ取っちゃん誰
って言われたときにあの国1でちゃう姫かねないと思うんですよというわけで今日の
動画は皆さんに私肇社長が同行で生活すればいいかを決めていただきたいと思います
宜しくお願いします
ちなみに肌着もずについていますあのちゃんの畑に早めに皆さんには言ってるんですよ
ちょっとしたら静岡札場所に移動するかも知れませんその覚悟がある上で畑に入りませ
んかって感じで聞いてるんでみんな絶対ついてくるので安心してください動画本当に
十分ですの東京新創刊もどっちでもいいったら当然生まれでも物件等がちゃんと撮れる
物件探してのが大変だと思ってるんで
癒し増加でもいい対応
おや探せばよさそうという理由であのこの動画のコメント欄で東京に蒸し増加に残るか
決めていただきたいと思います2月中にもコメント南に2個変えておきます静岡東京
って書いとくんでどっちかに good ボタンを押してください2月が私って多い方
に行きます
そこで閉めますよろしくお願いしますただねええ
もうそろそろちゃんと決めるべきだかもなんか迷っているようじゃダメだ
なんかもうモヤモヤするんですよねなんとかなるんじゃねえかという思い
こういうことだって馬力って動画やセブっていうの中はっきり決めないんでこういう時
はもうポイントせて決めようかみたいな感じで皆さんにお聞きいたしますあの
本当に迷っています皆さん皆さん投票の方
兄月いっぱいコメント永松しておりますので good パターンよろしくお願い致し
ます
一定畑にも聞いてみますか4思いついたぞ
ポジうーん
こそ成せるでな件
東京に少しまあ0
[音楽]
me
バッハ
出口すこ
というアンケートを取りますああ
あーなるほどなるほどそのてぃメリノコメント欄のグッドすべき目はなくて
まずんだまだは感ですコメント等のグッドスレってありがとうで8日静岡かでグって
コメントを2つ用意してぎゅっとするそうそうですけどそんなに急いで影響じゃないよ
ああゆくゆく
いいクロスどっちにしろ静岡居残りにしろと聞くこれにしろ
うんっ
まあ多分あれがだけだったらどっち間に使えねーって基盤なんかそうね2部卒が俺たち
を決め切れないんで食べてコインとても強いんでくれるみなさんの意見に沿ってはいい
んじゃないかというポイントですよけど持してね